uh
what is to be sung transpired in days of
yore
when the divine arkhan still walked the
earth
a dragon cast his curious gaze on the
world below
as he parted from the heavens that gave
his birth
the dragons sought truth amongst common
folk
but mortal trifles only fogged his mind
the wind-borne bard strummed his strings
dolce
and the holy liar answered his questions
kind
the dragons but a child full of wonder
and soared the heavens free from care
the bard's songs invited him to sing
along
for he yearned to let all perceive him
fair
enchanting legends the bard and dragon
were
but the tides of despair soon engulfed
the land
the lion fang perished and the falcon
plaque slept
as a vile dragon approached monsters
over the cathedral loomed death and his
friends
of the people's agony the bards soon
sang
the soaring dragon heeded his grave
and amidst the windstorms of brutal wars
[Music]
blood of venom sent the skydragon into
slumber
only to awake to be expelled in abhor
why do people in this age loathe me so
but the holy liar replied no more
wrath and woe vigor and venom
poured from the dragon's bitter eyes
the dragon's curse sprawled in silence
but the liar could no longer see his
cries
[Music]
wait you guys are
oh that's right you're the ones that
scared duval in a way
divalen who's that
huh oh right most people seem to call
him storm terror
why do you call him that are you too
meant to be close or something
oh so close hey
so pymon thinks this guy has a screw
loose
i'm venti the bard three-time winner of
the most popular part of monstat to be
precise
so what do you need from me given you
recognize us pymon doesn't believe we
need to explain any further
of course it's about storm terror storm
hey cut it with the amnesia act all
right show it to him
oh isn't this what
the crystal has been purified what
divalent he
the anguish he feels has brought him to
tears
tears
he was once such a gentle child now so
full of rage and suffering
i also came across a teardrop crystal
can you purify it
huh you really do have some wonderful
abilities
someone like you is going to end up
getting written into a bard's poem
oh a hero so bright should she stand in
the light
though stand in the shade and you'll be
met by a blade
alas i've really not the time to compose
a melody for you at this moment
anyway even if divalen is not taken down
his life will still wither away in the
breeze he'll burn himself out in the
flames of anger
i really must thank you for purifying
the teardrop crystal
it has helped me greatly but i've
already come to devise my own plan
oh and what plan would that be seeing
this tear has brought to mind a friend
so dear
friend one must be going hey
where are you running off to to the
symbol of monstat's hero
bye-bye huh
what do you make of that as far as he's
concerned you're a weirdo too you know
know what